Are your container images
too big? Are your container images insecure?
The sad truth is for most people, the
answer is yes
and yes.
The challenge
is that making small,
slim, secure
container images
requires a lot of understanding and knowledge
of container layers and optimizing
those layers.
But what if there was an easier way?
Today, we're gonna take a look at Slim
Toolkit by Slim AI.
This is an auto magical tool
for taking your existing container image pipelines
and making them more secure
and smaller.
Let's take a look. Let's start with the
test from a Slim Toolkit website. First, docker
image
pull nginx 1.19.
This is pulling down a version of the
NGINX image.
And if we run an image LS, we'll
see that this is a 33
meg in size.
We can do a Slim build NGINX one
nineteen using the name of the container image
already available on the Docker daemon.
This is now entering HTTP
probe mode.
This means that they have a special sensor
probe that queries the container
on web ports and tries to detect which
passer available and hits them to understand the
runtime components of your container image.
Kinda cool. Right?
Well, let's run docker image l s now.
And you'll see we have a new nginx
dot slim
that is 12 meg, under 12 meg.
But the question is,
does it work?
Let's do docker container run dash r m
to clean up nginx.slim
latest.
And so that I can hit this on
my local machine, let's publish the port
like so.
We're now running NGINX and the Slim container
exposing as port 80 on port eighty eighty
on the host.
So let's add the port binding to my
browser
and there you have it.
We're now on NGINX homepage served
by a Slim Toolkit slimmed and hardened and
secured
container image.
Let's kick it up a little bit and
try Slim Toolkit on a real Rust project
that I'm a big fan of called dog.
Dog is a dag replacement
for doing DNS queries.
It's super awesome. Go check it out.
I've already cloned dog to this local directory.
And now we can do docker image build
and we'll call this dog latest
in the current directory.
This may take just a moment, so bear
with me. So when we run Docker image
l s, grep for dog, we can see
that the dog image is 97.5
meg. So let's build the Slim Toolkit version.
First, we need to provide
a small script,
which I call exec dot s h,
which will use the application
that we're building the Slim image for.
It's best to try and get a well
rounded set of commands that use most of
the features
so that the sensor has the ability to
give you an image with the least margin
of error.
Here, I'm just telling dog to do three
different types of DNS lookup.
I actually don't think this case it helps
or expands the functionality of the command,
but you never know.
Now we could do Slim Build
and turn off the http probe and turn
on the exec file probe like so,
telling it the image that we wish to
build. In this case, dog latest, which again
is 97.5
meg.
We can see from the output here that
our exec script ran
and then Slim optimized after inspecting
our image.
So now if we run docker image l
s again, grepping for dog,
we'll see that our dog latest image at
97.5
meg has been reduced to under 10.
That is a huge saving.
But the question is,
does it work?
Let's try Docker container,
clean up after ourselves,
doc.slim
latest,
where we wish to run
a
NS lookup on Rawkode.studio.
And don't forget to pass in the command
itself.
And we get the NS records.
We can now say, do a CNAME lookup
on community.rawkode.academy,
or even google.com.
It looks like our dog command
works.
So for our last trick,
I'm taking a real production application.
This is the Rawkode Academy website.
I've cloned it to a directory here. Now
the things you need to know are one,
this application has never had a Dockerfile before.
I've dropped one into the directory that I
literally found by googling for astro build Dockerfile.
It was the first hit in the astro
docs.
What's important here is this image is 100%
unoptimized.
I know this is not a Dockerfile I
should be using for production.
Why?
Well, I'm using Node LTS,
which is fine, but probably we should be
using Alpine to
keep our footprint small.
I think copying the entire
working directory
rather than copying in the package dot JSON.
Doing the NPM install, copying in the rest,
performing in a build step, copying the static
assets, blah blah blah blah blah.
I shouldn't need
to know all this stuff.
Most people don't.
We then just tell it to run the
application from the desk folder like nobody is
watching.
And if you do a build of this
Dockerfile
and do an LS and I'll just filter
for only this,
we have a container image at a whopping
1.4
gig.
Now I have written articles on how to
avoid this situation,
but what I'm about to show you is
magic.
You don't need to optimize anything. Docker Slim
will do it for you. To see what
our applications
should look like, let's run the big image.
We do docker container run dash dash r
m to clean it up when we're finished.
We have a port mount
and port eighty eighty just like before. This
time to port 3,000 within the container.
And then we provide
the image
name.
Now we can open
a previous NGINX page
and refresh.
And we get the Rawkode Academy website.
We can click on services,
shows,
community,
which is an external link, and so forth.
So let's try
the slim version.
First thing we need to do
is slim
build.
And then pass website
latest.
By default, Slim is going to use the
HTTP
probe. And by default,
that probe is going to check every page
for links to other pages on your website
and try to discover as much as possible.
So let's give that a moment to finish.
And done.
Let's take a look
at the image sizes.
Gripping for the websites alone.
As you can see, our original image was
over one gig pushing towards two.
Here,
our Slim image is a hundred meg.
So it begs the question,
does it work?
Let's copy our Docker run command and this
time we'll do website
dot Slim.
Then let's jump back
and refresh.
And that is looking
not too bad.
Let's click on services
and shows
and even Rawkode Live.
Hey,
that is pretty sweet.
So Slim Toolkit is a pretty amazing tool.
You don't need to fight with Docker files
anymore.
You don't need to grok and understand and
balance and juggle the layers to get the
output that you need.
With just a few commands, the Slim Toolkit
can take your huge
or maybe just chunky container images
and spit out a secure
and slim alternative.
So go check it out.
We'll see you soon.